tu dois passer à l'étape suivante de ton
voyage ah bon j'ai pu être le Guerrier
Dragon tu seras promu guide spirituel de
la vallée de la
paixisis manger légumes
nou ça marche pas du
[Musique]
tout ta long je suis
fan quand je posséderai le Kung Fu des
plus grands
méchants personne n'osera douter de mon
pouvoir pas même
l'illustre guerrier dragon c'est qui ça
la plus puissante sorcière polymorphe la
caméléone et comment je la trouve cette
la caméléone je vais t'amener tout droit
devant sa
porte on est face à une armée
alors on va créer notre armée à nous
mais on est où là les plus grands escro
et criminels vivent ici tu es une
criminelle recherchée tu as l'air étonné
c'est étonnant attention les enfants les
feux d'artifice c'est
dangereux la violence chatouille le
bidon pourquoi on vous aiderait on peut
battre la caméléone tous ensemble
Guerrier Dragon c'est ce que je fais de
mieux j'y connais quoi en GUID
spirituelle sérieux que tiens-tu dans la
main cookie tu as été choisi pour être
bien plus que ce que tu es
déjà comment on règle ça V sans douleur
ou lentement avec douleur lentement avec
douleur tu as trouvé un rival à ta
mesure caméléon
on se ressemble toi et
moiouche laisse faire je vais lui beauté
mes
[Musique]
fesses